the impact smart healthy Shoppers are
having in the marketplace is profound we
hear it every day companies are
struggling in some cases to reformulate
some of them are coming into our program
and reformulating their products
completely because they want our seal
that's what you should feel hopeful
about every time you make a better
choice you send a signal to the
marketplace economy that safer choices
are a good thing make more of them take
a look at your food supply look at
processed foods there we rate the
nutrition we call out the contaminants
in all of those areas we've really tried
to do our best to empower consumers who
live in the real world